hello everyone who is now currently on
Twitch for streaming this live on Twitch
initially uh hello YouTube I today
really wanted to play the full spoken
demo and this is the demo that came out
about a month ago but I was in Australia
and I didn't take my recording setup
just so that I would have proper family
time so I'm effectively playing catch up
um I don't really know what to expect
from this but I have had a lot of
opinions on trailers of this game
um very mixed I've not loved a lot of
the dialogue I did not like the editing
of the original trailer but I also
thought that the combat actually does
look pretty cool so I'm going into this
still having a lot of questions about
this game
um I'm glad there's a demo I want to try
it game comes pretty comes out pretty
pretty soon this is a Square Enix game
thank you for playing the full spoken
demo in which you can enjoy a sample of
the full game Please be aware okay
your progress will be saved
automatically do not turn off the power
while the icon is on screen
and yeah I thought the traversal looked
really good
as well so um yeah this is publicly
available Daydreamer
cat lover New Yorker on a fateful
evening her life changed drastically
when she was mysteriously transported to
the beautiful treacherous land of athia
it looks very Final Fantasy the magical
sentient bracelet inexplicably wrapped
around her arm then discovers she can
cast powerful spells I think people
might look cool to swiftly Traverse the
sprawling Landscapes the last remnants
of atheist populous soon look to prey as
their only hope for confronting the
tantas once benevolent matriarchs who
now rule as maddened and Evil
sorceresses
desperate to find a way back home Frey
sets off on a journey it's very strange
izakai anime theme
of course
okay let's do it
I've not seen anybody play this um
either just by knowing it's been out for
a little while so this is my first jump
into it
very curious how much I'm gonna like it
I couldn't tell you
okay yes
what would happen if I said no
all right it's kind of neat it's like
it's just a very streamlined
oh cool
very assassin's creedy or modern
assassin's Creedence
it looks pretty
simple
attack Magic Use attack magic to defeat
oncoming enemies press R2 and unleash an
attack spell and hold it down
to build up power before casting switch
between various attack spells by using
R1
yeah
now's your chance
on it I probably oh no I've got two hang
on
yeah or their Shield shots
who's talking to me is it the ribbon
oh I didn't expect swearing
okay I don't like that one I'll go back
to that one
that's that's easy it's sort of like um
OG Fable King is a mammala style
it was very clunky obviously but
support magic support magic provides
various beneficial effects you can use
it to gain tactical advantages such as
slowing or even stopping fast moving
enemies allowing you to Blossom with
attack spells press L2 to cast a support
spell in L1 to open a menu that will
allow you to switch between them
bro that was sick
how to switch switch is here
I wouldn't have thought that was a
support spell weirdly
um hang on it's no one I want to swap
between
this looks like a big one no
I'm not sure why I'm not doing that oh
it just oh it just took a while okay
um tendril bleach give it a try
it's a little awkward to change between
spells
I don't know positive wire wasn't
Crossing them really
what's this
cool 39 points
um so the
these you just can't use often
here we go what's the thing at the top I
guess it'll probably teach me that right
switching between spell sets you can use
another style of Magic by switching to
the appropriate spell set press R1 and
L1 to open up spell switching menu then
select from two available styles
incoming you guys that's cool try this
for size
now I'm unsure what I'm doing wrong it's
making me not uh charge properly
I like that
and then I guess we can swap again
I think you've defeated several enemies
never mind
she's a little bit too chatty nope
nope whoa
don't use it damn it I don't know how to
cancel
okay
[ __ ]
uh
uh no I didn't really put it together
super well but that's my fault probably
I can sometimes are just terrible at
tutorials while doing something on
Twitch as well yeah she definitely talks
a little bit too much which we weren't
worried about
um check objectives
go to the central refuge in the Water
Garden okay
thank you
it was called Force bucket after all
uh okay
so I think what I was getting confused
about was why L2
wasn't working when I expected it to we
wait until it's actually come back I'm
also kind of covering it so I should
move myself over hang on
maybe I should go over here
um so when I hit L2
still can't use it
it's long recovery well let's just do
this one
so leech has to be used on myself
I think
yeah it just looks like these were
obviously they all passive spells but
they were so passive that to me it
almost looked like
um I wasn't using them at all and that
was confusing me in combat
might as well pocket this
I wonder if I can just attack random
stuff is there a like a melee that
doesn't require
yeah I would like to try that though
thanks
that's pretty neat in fact you can do it
on anything is cool
this looks breakable let's try it
no
okay uh it's a very Bland world I will
say that
is initially noticeable
pretty bland
timing I must say
I could take a nap
I think I have full help but why not
wait am I covering something now on the
bottom left as well
thank you
shall we oh I am the health okay leave
it again Let's do let's just go up here
shall we small one I'll beat that one
right underneath
and I think that won't cover anything
all right
long long ago the taunters built spiers
of stone across Athea the tontus power
was so great that no sooner had they
decided to build them then the spies
appeared all over the land one day these
spiers these monuments shall save one of
the taunters with great anticipation in
her eyes
deep
okay
so I think I just slept in some random
person's house
which is cool I can't even open the
door I
have you
uh Watchtower like easy soaps
um okay chill chill all right
very Ubisoft yes
oh that's interesting
hmm
I like this this is a neat idea I guess
we probably want to go to that one no
photo spot that's interesting too
thless
we're just gonna go on the bridge
that's what I think we're gonna do feels
like a reskin Assassin's Creed
definitely a lot more similar to
Assassin's three than I think I was even
expecting for some reason
are they all bad
okay
so what how do I use this
like it has to like cover you on the
ground or something
um battle teacher elevation and Magic
parkour you can use magikarpur to dodge
parkour did I say copper to dodge enemy
attacks in battle press
circle at the right moment to take a
quick step out of the way you can also
hold down ill and circle we'll perform
the magic Poco to evade automatically
okay
yeah see I'm not fully sure what that
did
just controls a bit weird
um okay let's do this one okay and then
change this one to bind because in
theory bind tool just that makes more
sense
I really want to be able to hit somebody
with like a sword or something
you know what I mean
uh hang on there was a shield in here as
well wasn't there
no no that's wrong
um
I think that was a shield spell
somewhere but uh I think it's this and
then that one oops
this one this one
and then charge
okay
I don't remember I swear there was one
but I've lost it I like this magic set a
lot more than the other one that's for
sure
then
yes Shields I don't know I swear it was
there and now I've lost it my bad okay
[Music]
I don't know I still feel like I'm very
clunky but we'll figure it out
I like the OST too I'm liking the music
a lot yeah
foreign
let's do the charge give it a try
that's cool
how do I use the attack that's on the
top that's it
I'm sure
I also feel like this is probably a
thing where you'll use the same one
spell
[Music]
foreign
would have been nice a while ago okay
use all three while in enemies in View
and you'll see that lock on icon appears
okay
am I locked yet I mean this is a cool
looking fight oh come on come on oh
thank you for the raid Bruce's goose is
touch
which um I'm definitely just trying to
get the hang of
[Music]
so the thing is I need to change this
every time because it runs out of charge
so fast right
do that increases my attack power that's
cool
the jumping in and out is fun
the way the park law Works in in combat
is fun I like it
okay phrase magical powers have
increased
so much harsher than I kept expecting
not the most impressive sweet a nugget
hey okay he's a freebie
give an audit chain so they didn't run
out
oh that's interesting maybe I do need to
mess with some settings I'm going to
leave it how it is because it's the demo
you know
take off slow down time and settings
um I think I probably would do that for
my own playthrough but I feel like I
should be demoing the demo as as it is
made I know she's a New Yorker
oh my God I want to collect everything
what have you done to me the traversal
is fine I like it
not certain I'm going the right way
[ __ ]
we're just gonna go to this marker
I got a little troublemakers where the
weak one oh the deer
top spell is these two together
well that's fun
I definitely like this sword thing I
just can't see any reason why I would
ever change it
your skills are coming along because I
like it like a lot oh compared to the
other stuff
so changing it is this Arc slice rage
slice lost slice yeah we like ox slice
but maybe that's fine maybe I can just
choose the one I want
Crucible not a huge fan of
yeah I'm gonna stick with charge
and maybe that's the idea is that you're
supposed to
just have combos that you like
foreign
like maybe I'm not supposed to be wildly
creeps swapping between them all the
time
that's interesting somebody blinding me
Dodge rolls if you use magic Buckle
whilst preparing a spell you can make an
even bigger invasive maneuver than they
usually put sidestep apparent attack or
support spell hold are two or three then
hold on okay cool
this and then that
you know why I didn't expect her to
swear
why are we facing this way lad
oh because that's the thing I need to
get
okay I immediately like the comment more
than I did very quickly
that's cool
so to finish the job I probably need to
get something ranged
foreign
can get kind of close
um okay let's oh
maybe the reason this swearing is
surprising me is that like I felt like
some of the trailers were kind of family
friendly I don't know
like it just didn't come across to me as
something that would have any swearing
um okay hang on I need to change this to
this probably okay
to have more Rage which didn't really
did I not take it okay maybe I did with
boss lights
now I did okay
did she not throw that there we go
it just took a while to change Maybe
damn
I do like that
[Music]
is he using both of them why am I I
didn't I'm swept oh I swapped between
them when I'm when I've thrown one of
them and it's just doing that
automatically okay got it
nope
I have to hold it down maybe nope it's
not working I think that's it I have to
hold it down
Jack
I'm also like not good with the lock on
it's not something that I am succeeding
at very well for some reason
all right
there we go
work that time
all right we've done it it's a little
finicky
but again could be on me I'm always
really bad at tutorials while streaming
um
because my brain is doing too many
things at once
what do we got here
oh
a cloak all right
um I guess I'll take the one that gives
me the health
do that one
pretty
yet another remarkable fight oh yeah the
treasure Seeker strikes again
okay
uh what do we go from here this way you
want me to go this way I guess
you found the combat a bit clunky
overall
that's comforting
not me anyway
didn't like that line
I'm just picking up some roses for some
reason my guy just just getting some
flowers you know
oh yeah there is teleport okay hang on
how do I do that
here
map
we are going
there
can I
teleport there
fast travel destination list
no just the one I've been to so did I
just run away from it is that what
happened what was go back here
and then go to the ah to the right are
we here again here please tell me your
jokes
oh is there fall damaged let's find out
only one way to find out
it's fine tolerable
it clicked me when I realized I need to
keep holding Circle and moving and using
abilities while in the air okay maybe I
need to be a little bit more mobile no
sweat
I think this does look really nice
little crocodilios
look water
[Laughter]
I mean she's not wrong
[Laughter]
technically yeah
this is very assassin's creedy
climb even higher with multiple leaps in
quick succession okay
cool
objective three complete
let me just pick up some more flowers
don't know what they're for yet but I'll
pick them up I mean this is quite a
pretty Vista I like the scale
and I think I like the camera
um
placement two I can kind of be picky
about how close over the shoulder
shall we
I guess if they give you
boss traveled from the jump you should
assume it's a pretty big world
and I am aware that I could Foster all
that I'm cool
with the traversal finale
I get that eventually you probably don't
want to do it anymore but I'm cool
[Music]
so someone in the chat said that I
should try and hold down Circle at all
times but then I can't control the
camera
so that is a little bit tough
foreign
just took a little bit of learning
hey get out of here get out of here okay
well this is happening
stupid bird
they took so much damage from that bird
dude
okay
it's cool
I kind of want more of a challenge
I'm very glad to hear it
I'm not sure what I'm running towards
but
you know what I will say
right now someone in chat might have
said this
um give it a try
thus far the world kind of does remind
me of Sonic Frontiers
and that's not a take I expected to have
uh okay
you need to break this
working here cool
okay
do I do it is it done oh there we go
just do me a read
okay those are just gonna be like a
little upgrade
stations then I take it
wait what
that's me finishing the demo no no I was
like what
okay
gosh I should say that new ability was
just up and I know
foreign
there's a limit to it is my guess
I can't just run up forever
I don't think no I can't okay
no sir
um
let me take a look at them
was there some other stuff that I can do
I just don't know that I'm gonna find it
all super interesting Scout the area
let me zoom out
and this is a pretty big slice of map to
be honest especially for a demo this is
probably gonna be a massive game
defeat the boss within the time limit
mutant
let's go do this one
assuming I have not already done it
fast travel destination list it's still
just these two all right so let's go
here
cause I'm right by it how do I get up
though
other side of the bridge maybe probably
which is fear that it's gonna be empty
yeah
I sense a hostile presence be on your
car yeah that's fine yeah yeah stay
frosty got it
performs cup scan
of course of course yeah
I don't even know what I'm fighting
um
people what are you
some sort of orc a goblin
let's focus
guess that already
that's not doing much well
oh come on
thank you
I do like this this um
sword to spear situation we've got going
on here I'm a fan
I think I left someone behind me okay
it's fine
not you
all right is this the boss I have to
kill within time limit
hey buddy
know that I don't want to do this I
think you look very cute
unless I'm so sad about it
I don't know wait what did you do
I don't know what you did what did we
just
we're not on the same page
hello sir J double thank you
[Music]
it this is pretty easy now still like a
little bit awkward but
because you sort of Auto Dodge when you
hold down
Circle when I'm just fighting one thing
and I'm locked onto it and I'm just kind
of moving around it
oh no I am taking damage but let's go
back and then restore
what else am I supposed to do
it's gonna hurt my hands for sure
oh
but I think it did have some
accessibility options so maybe we'll
take a look at this it's the pressing
circle is killing me already
I mean I think the visual effects if
that's the right one it probably is
oh very pretty
hmm
how did he even get me come on
oh gosh
all right
I'm kind of a spell expert at this point
so I did it
[Music]
I would not say I enjoyed that fight
um okay let's have a look at the
accessibility options I was like I'm not
going to because it's a demo we'll just
keep it how it is but then my hand's
Gonna Hurt So
I love automatically I am Gathering
CNN highlighted my characters spell
switching menu toggle hold I feel like
hold makes sense
magic toggle
toggle seems good
semi-auto
not sure about that
yeah
isn't it that
okay they actually don't have something
that can prevent me from
it's gonna be this one
Sprint into this
maybe I didn't see them
sprint button
run by using L3
and run with magic
but it's
if I press L3 it doesn't do it
unless that's referring to sprinting
without magic pockets okay I get that
that makes sense
okay but
are you eating plastic back there
you are
that's not great he doesn't swallow it
thankfully
um
spot take from the game slash demo what
you played I only just started really
and I don't have any hot takes
still
now goes
um I could probably cause trouble here
and then end up a bit
we're here that really was miraculously
fast so far I mean no hot takes but I
think that it looks pretty
and
the controls are a little bit awkward
but it could just be that it has like a
lighting period and then it it gets
better
um I think the the world that it's just
seen in this demo of course is just a
demo of Game of Throne development this
isn't even necessarily
a slice of the game at all
um is a bit boring
a little bit dull but uh I don't feel
confident in any of those
did you notice and yeah agree very glad
that they provide a
demo at all love that especially for a
game that like a lot of people did have
strong opinions on based on someone's
favorable trailers
yeah I do think she talks
and she's a little bit too Clippy
yeah what he said is not my favorite
I can basically zone out and play this
though but I am getting grade ease so
it's like I'm playing it well I'm sure
if you actually swap between spells and
wait well it looks very different
that was only empties that's not a good
idea foreign
the placement of those particular lines
is just a little bit weird right like
you're not joking are you
okay
um when we were just running into combat
this is a little bit weird
hello banjo what you doing down there
slip and stuff that's cool
he's cool looking this enemy
and yeah again based on the E grade I
imagine I'm just playing it really badly
like I'm not playing the way I'm
supposed to be playing
with crazy Breeze
um she's actually not talking to herself
life on the couch I think I saw you say
that before she's actually not talking
to herself she's talking to the cop so
you're not hearing her inner thoughts
you're hearing her talk to someone
else
it's all I think the issue is like a lot
of it's very generic dialogue
as well
um which makes perfect sense if it's hot
like they're just really going for that
with like the isakai
she's just supposed to be a regular old
New York teen but um
don't need to tell me twice
I don't know something about it feels
very mobile
again I think I'm probably playing it
really cool
hello little banjo are you being a good
dog
are you eat a good dog down here oh
that's it
um
okay
so I think I probably played it
incorrectly I was I wasn't swapping
between the weapons
um or the abilities because I didn't
really want to right
but that's on me for like wasting my
part of the demo
you definitely wanted me to but I didn't
really like some of the others
and it probably should have been but I
didn't really want to
I think it's very pretty I think the
score is really nice
foreign
[Music]
you think maybe I should just like
swap back and keep playing them I should
try some of the other
Trump some of the other abilities
probably
because I didn't think it would end that
fast
that is my badge
I wonder if I can hit continue or I have
to start a new one
foreign
okay so it's because the ox slice is
just the default of this
it's clearing holes it gives you rage
slice of oil
um here we've got
I don't mind it keeps me on my toes did
I screw that up or are they gonna help
me and that's what they do
and if we do this oh this goes
yeah I just don't like these as much
but we can swap between that's the
shield shot creative defensive Shield
while charging okay
then use it as an attackball
okay
um
come on
sorry right now I'm almost not paying
attention to what I'm doing at all um oh
okay that's cool because I just finished
my job from it I'm not really uh using
everything I mean I like that a lot
but like I can't imagine why then don't
answer what you doing you want to go
poop is always being [ __ ] up uh most
abilities change if you're in the air
yeah so how do I get in the air
uh
um because just circle doesn't get in
the air
unless you're running over something
this isn't X is not jump X is jump but
do you mean just by pressing X
okay
because that seems odd
I mean like that thing
X is regular human jump right yeah X is
regular human jump which doesn't seem
like it's going to change my abilities
no it doesn't
maybe this one like like I do this no
that how do I get airborne
oh it is you have to do the pothole so
that means it's kind of limited because
you can only do it like
on really specific things right
um and you would have to keep running
away and then running back in that's the
idea
yeah that's probably gonna kill me
do this
if we run away
not doing much that just waited for me
to land there are better jumps you can
unlock okay got it because yeah if right
now I'm jumping I'm just like I just
have to go back to this rock all the
time
just feels a bit strange I don't know
but again my grade being so low means
this game probably wants you to
constantly swap between moves but
because I don't like most of them like
I'd never use the shield shot I would
straight up
always use these
seal as magic I don't know who Sealy is
but I just can't see myself wanting to
use the other side which means I'm kind
of not
playing it correctly
um
magic do I have some upgrades available
to me
switch skill Street
oh I do have some stuff I can learn
fix enemies backwards of fiery Force
Trigger next but that's cool
how you do it I wonder
[Music]
who's level to Bubble Up beneath the
enemy and simmer away from a hot minute
someone's a host of fiery soldiers who
attacking I mean that's cool
question mark all light in the darkness
that increases the speed at which
stamina charges don't care summons the
protective power of cleansing Flame
Dragon drop oh a raged attack that
strikes distant enemies and pulls them
closer switching to Silas magic that's
cool
lost slice level two
uh I can't see an extended jump in here
but uh switch skill tree huh
there we go
I don't mind this UI
strikes and poisonous enemy over a white
area
allows you use crafting skills to
increase the amount by which a necklace
will put your health
fire seeds into enemies that continue to
deal damage control period
is that the jump one where is Jump
um is there a different skill menu
idea
I'm not sure if there's a difference
coming uh okay gears we could look at
this too I liked the cloak what about
necklaces
just this one they don't do a toning
different stuff that I'm aware of
power yeah I don't know
um
again clearly I'm not playing it the way
it's intended because I'm not swapping
between the skills because I don't like
some of them as much as just the sword
combo thing I've got going on here
and I recognize that
it's supposed to apparently get more
Airborne but
like
that's it
people say being Airborne changes
controls but like this one just doesn't
even work if I may have one it makes me
land
um
or I guess it's already that I have it
uh
let's do the that one I like that
I strike in here where are they where
they at
big alligators
yeah yeah it just didn't work
I don't know man this is one of those
ones where I feel like I'm doing things
wrong because the grades are so low and
my brain feels very scattered about it
um
I guess I should have been holding R2
more huh that does create more combos
but yeah I like that one anyway
Rock slice lost slice I was probably
just tapping onto too much could have
been a big part of it
let's try that hold down all two strange
that it does a tutorial and it didn't
tell me any of it
no that's just like a charge up for that
one
does not super interesting
so yeah I don't know I think that the
score is awesome I think visually it's
like very the combat is visually very
impressive
um
I feel like the combat is just sort of
odd in a way that again feels like it's
my fault
and not the game's fault and this is
maybe one of those games that I needed
to play not on Twitch because it makes
me way worse at tutorials or anything
that requires any kind of learning
um
and I don't love the writing which like
I think we kind of knew I was hoping it
wouldn't be that way in the final
release but it does feel like it's that
way unfortunately
um a little bit too quippy a little bit
too
marvely a little bit too generic is the
issue but this is just a tiny little
slice so there are things that I think
are cool and they're kind of the same
things that I already thought were cool
from the trailers and there are things
that I don't love so much
I think I'll still give it a chance but
my ultimate verdict is
this isn't something I'm excited to play
and it feels like it's on me
and maybe if I go watch other people
play it and then try the demo again I'll
have a different experience because like
I think I'm maybe just not approaching
it correctly which isn't a thing I
thought I would even have to think about
it does feel a little bit like Sonic
Frontiers funnily enough does feel a
little bit like Assassin's Creed
um
hey it's not the worst thing in the
world but like I said I wouldn't say I'm
like excited to play Mormon so
that's the verdict ultimately I think it
does come out in a couple of weeks so
I'm curious to travel